at least 12 google play games like
without in template in sale viagra u
here about 50 different types of
soviet slot machines, most
of which work five alexandr
vibrance to mezim observer okay things on
in saint petersburg brushes coming to our
museum the visitor gets a handful of
real soviet  coins with the help of
which the machines were launched 25 years
ago and now this return to 80 is
happening with the help of tactile
sensations and everything that
games can do for an hour farfan from the point of view of the
developers of Soviet slot
machines, attempts were made to make
machines that
do not say so and entertain develop it
it’s hard and up to the field of dagames
with trees Berlin cereal is not behind it to the
root of the n max sword of the seventy-fifth
year in the Soviet Union they began to produce a
slot machine a bicycle to invent it was
no longer necessary to take the most popular
machines simplified them a bit due to
getting up in electronics
therefore Soviet slot machines  no
memory
points no competitive  ia with previous
players and games
and won the first place queries in a
driver's that is, this is exactly the same
entertaining and sporting some kind of
rifle military machines that
all over the world is just not a boy adapted
to Russian soviet real life until the day
wild for prepayment sergey lunin
four  a five-year-old child
has a great time at our museum,
he does not pass himself up with the
Soviet Union, he is just interested in
playing